yay recently announced that it's beloved
horror game dead space would be getting
its very own
remake seems like a good idea after
capcom's success with its resident evil
2 remake
recently i feel like we've been seeing
more and more remakes and remasters
which may be thanks to video games
getting older as a medium
and i don't think that's necessarily a
bad thing while i love seeing new ips
and sequels to games i love as much as
anyone else
i also really like the idea of being
able to share games i grew up on that i
consider classics with a new generation
especially the ones that haven't aged
all that gracefully you know some of
those early polygonal games like final
fantasy vii
tomb raider or goldeneye so here is my
list of 10 games
or franchises that deserve a remake or
remaster
to note i'm concerning a remake to be
something that's completely remade from
the ground up
similar to resident evil 2 whereas i
consider remastering something that's
a graphical overhaul maybe with some
minor mechanics of justice similar to
crash bandicoot insane trilogy
from software burst into mainstream
gaming prominence thanks to hidetaka
miyazaki and the soul series
demon souls dark souls and bloodborne
were all instant classics
and some of the best games of the modern
gaming generation
and i'm not leaving out securo or
hopefully elden ring
sometimes you just have to list less
things for brevity's sake but
before hitataki miyazaki and souls from
software had actually been around
for a long time with their first game
being a launch title for the playstation
1.
since then they've created a few
properties that stood out such as
armored core
and shadow tower but what i think truly
deserves the remake
remastered treatment is king's field
this game and this one were so ahead of
their time
when king's field's first western game
released many american critics dunked on
it for being too slow methodical
and not as fast-paced as doom because
back then
if it was a first person game every
single thing had to be compared to doom
but the thing is at their core these
games were absolutely fantastic
leveling up and enemies were incredibly
well balanced and exploration was always
rewarding
the games did a fantastic job at
managing risk and reward during
exploration with a plethora of weapons
armor and equipment that your character
could find which genuinely helped in
your progression
without feeling utterly broken the games
had an interesting and creepy
vibe to their maze-like labyrinths and
with a healthy dose of imagination
many of these areas were truly haunting
and spooky
but the blocky graphics definitely don't
hold up today
especially in the first few games of the
series
while there was a far better looking ps2
sequel kingsfield the ancient city
even that could use a nice boost with an
overall graphical jump and a reworking
of some of the dungeon design of the
earlier games
i truly think a kingsfield remastered
collection would be an
absolute gem and there's enough from
software fans today who would appreciate
it
[Music]
okay this might be a controversial
suggestion
but i'm going to stand by it the mario
franchise features some of the
greatest platform games ever made and
they have truly stood the test of time
and mario 64 was absolutely
revolutionary for his time
it defined what a 3d platformer could be
back before anyone knew how to navigate
platforming in a 3d space
and it pretty much invented the 3d
collect-a-thon genre
but and you knew it was coming
today the game feels a little clunky
the camera control is completely
outdated and the platforming itself
honestly feels a little off and not as
tight as future entries in the mario
series
i don't think design-wise anything
really needs to change with this title
it's still a classic and honestly the
smaller levels of the game compared to
today's level size
i actually think is a plus sometimes 3d
collect-a-thons get bogged down in
worlds that are overly big and empty
if mario 64 received a graphical upgrade
similar to what super mario all-stars
did for the nes mario games
new camera controls and slightly less
clunky controls
i truly think it would modernize one of
gaming's biggest classics and be the
best way to introduce the game to an all
new generation
and look i know there was a nintendo ds
remaster back in 2004
but i'm talking about a complete
graphical and control overhaul
think about peach's castle from mario
odyssey but for
all of mario 64. just please don't make
it a limited release
nintendo chrono trigger is often
considered one of the greatest games of
all time
in fact it's my personal favorite game
of all time that is
why i have both of these that's just how
much i love this game
so do i think it needs a remake no
it's perfect as is the music is some of
the best in gaming the graphics are
charming and the gameplay is absolutely
spot on
that said it's also one of those games
that might eventually get lost to time
ironically given the time travel nature
of the game and that's the great thing
about remakes and remasters
as i mentioned at the beginning of this
video it introduces these properties to
an entirely new set of gamers
remakes with square enix are a bit of a
gamble
on one hand you might get this taken in
setsu 3 remake
which enhances the game in some ways but
is a detriment in others
you might get the secret of mana remake
which is well
better left not talked about or you
might get the final fantasy 7 treatment
which while different is a fantastic
game in its own right
and a loving tribute to the original
game chrono trigger deserves that love
and you know what i play chrono trigger
for the perfect game it is
if the game received the ff7 remake
treatment i'd still always have that
original game to play and i'd be excited
to see what new ways the game could be
remixed
like one of your favorite musical tracks
but with a new twist to it
while we're on the topic of square enix
ff7 has seen the love it deserves and i
cannot wait for part 2.
but another classic that's slowly
becoming forgotten is
final fantasy vi ff6 was
in my opinion the pinnacle of the 2d
final fantasy games
kefka is still one of gaming's greatest
villains and while the game is
absolutely
stunning in 2d and i love pixel art
if it was recreated properly in 3d it
could be a visual spectacle
just imagine that opera scene fully
realized in a 3d setting
similar to ff7 final fantasy vi could be
a visual feast with a completely
overhauled remake
and that's not to say there's anything
wrong with the original game
there isn't just that square enix did a
fantastic job with his treatment of
final fantasy vii
and i'd love to see how that could be
applied to six
metal gear solid will never be the same
without hideo kojima
his vision is part of what made these
games so it's a little hard to imagine
any future sequels without his
involvement
but these games still are classics and
while metal gear solid 4 and 5 had
carried the torch
i do feel like it would be great to see
metal gear solid 1 and 2 remade for
modern systems
and as a way for newer metal gear solid
fans to play the originals
while mgs1 was remade as the twin stakes
for the gamecube
that was still nearly 20 years ago there
actually are rumors circulating that
metal gear solid could be getting hd
remastered treatments for the first four
titles
and i am all for it remember how i
mentioned chrono trigger was my favorite
game of all time
well mega man is a strong competitor for
my attention and love
but i honestly don't feel there's too
much that could be improved on those
games
the platforming is tight the graphics of
even the earlier games have aged
surprisingly well
as the pixlr was just that good for the
series and the music is still some of
gaming's best
the thing is 2d platform games are one
of the genres that can't really gain too
much from a 3d update
if anything it can risk destroying the
charm of those pixel graphics
but there was a 3d mega man game that
could
actually benefit from a modern remake
mega man legends
despite being relatively obscure for the
franchise the game is
charming and well deserving of more
attention
thanks to this qc look mega man legends
doesn't actually look
too terrible for playstation 1 era game
but imagine how the game could look with
modern cel-shaded graphics to enhance
its anime style
and while the gameplay was good in
concept it suffered from being one of
the first 3d console games
by today's standards controlling mega
man feels stiff and could definitely use
an
upgrade resident evil and silent hill
have long been considered to the best
survival horror
franchises and while resident evil has
thrived
both with fantastic remakes and
remasters that have managed to capture
the spirit of the original games
but with updated sensibilities as well
as great sequels that have been
generally well received by fans
sadly silent hill has had the opposite
fate
while silent hill 2 and 3 both received
hd remasters in 2012
silent hill 2's remake was completely
butchered
missing the atmospheric fog that was an
integral part of the game
the less said about those remakes the
better but as we've seen with the
resident evil franchise
horror games in particular benefit from
remakes with better sound and graphics
and the silent hill franchise truly is
deserving of this
while much of the horror of these games
is psychological a true visual upgrade
would only serve to enhance this
rather than detract from it ever since
the madness of abandon
which i covered in our video abandoned
in the silent hill conspiracy
there have been constant rumors of a new
silent hill game
konami announced a partnership earlier
this year with bloober team who
developed the medium and blair witch
which many have speculated could be to
create a new silent hill game
on the other hand there have also been
rumors that a reboot is already in the
works for silent hill
in the late 90s and early aughts teenage
rebellion took the form of
extreme sports punk music and elements
of hip-hop
while tony hawk pro skater excellently
incorporated this with its now well
beloved franchise
there was another game that resonated
with me even more
jet set radio just at radio and its
sequel
just at radio future sees you playing as
a rebel rollerblade gang
tagging the streets of tokyo too with
graffiti and escaping from the cops
while tony hawk was primarily about
seeing how many tricks you could combo
in a given time limit
chess set radio was unique in combining
these tricking elements alongside an
actual
objective of tagging the neighborhoods
of the game with rival gangs and the
cops acting as antagonists who could
actually hurt the player
meanwhile its sequel just set radio
feature increased the verticality of the
level design making every area a unique
trick fest
tony hawk pro skater oneplus 2 showed
that updating the style of game truly
does work
not only graphically but with new
elements and
the world of tokyo 2 deserves that kind
of treatment
around the same time the first smash
brothers game released to the n64
the dreamcast and arcades were getting
their very own unique 3d brawler
power stone power stone and power stone
2 were collectively 2
incredibly fun takes on the fighting
game genre while fighting games had gone
3d well before these games released
power stone made the entire arena part
of your arsenal with characters able to
pick up chairs
bombs and other weapons they could toss
at enemies or utilize
powerstone2 took this a step further
introducing four player matches
and moving interactive arenas that meant
these arenas weren't just background
flavor but each brought unique
challenges you would have to overcome
while fighting
similar to some of the arenas of smash
brothers there were even bosses in
powerstone 2 and an overwhelming amount
of things you could
unlock through playing sadly due to only
being ported to the dreamcast the games
never saw the love and attention they
deserved
however there's rumors that capcom
leaked plans to release a remake of the
game
possibly even later this year there are
some genres that have slowly died over
time
and one of those was the jet ski
waverunner
speedboat racer jet moto in particular
stood out for its creative track designs
while the game started typically enough
you're in water and have a few ramps
you'll jump off of
eventually you'll find yourself racing
in forests along broken bridges
through snowy mountains and in swamps
jet motion took this further with the
course that took you through heaven and
hell part of what made these games so
fun was the insane amount of air you
could get with each ramp and how you'd
have to deal with the consequences of it
which could result in disaster
similarly you also had a number of
boosts which could serve to launch you
in the first place or potentially launch
you off the side of a cliff
into a wall or a void the last game in
the series
jet moto 3 was released in 1999
and sadly another game was never
released
but enough realistic racers while the
cart games are a load of fun
what the world needs is a return of jet
moto
if it's not clear many of the games
listed are close to my heart
and i'm not against sequels or new ips i
just love gaming in general
and part of that means wanting to share
my passion and what games made me fall
in love with gaming
i think that's one of the most valuable
things about these remakes and remasters
we've been seeing lately
allowing a fresh new set of eyes on some
of gaming's best
what games would you love to see remade
for modern generation
and are there any from my list you agree
with or disagree with
let me know in the comments below and i
can't wait to see your picks
[Music]
you